JEN KING: Hi, I'm
Jen King, and I'm
the Technical Lead on
the Drive Android API.
Today I'm going to talk about
the DriveEventService, which
allows your app to respond
to background events.
First, we'll cover change
events, which notify you
of changes to a particular item.
Next, we'll introduce
completion events,
which tell you the outcome
a particular action.
For example, whether
a file you created
was uploaded successfully.
Last, we'll show you how to use
completion events to resolve
conflicts when multiple
apps or multiple devices
edit the same file.
Let's get started.
Some of you may already be
aware of change event listeners,
which allow you to listen for
changes to a particular item
while your app is running.
But what if you want to
inform users that a file
they're interested
in has changed
while your app isn't running.
The newly added change
event subscriptions
allow you to do just that.
Subscriptions deliver
exactly the same events
as are delivered to a
change event listener,
but you request them
and receive them
in a slightly different way.
To add a change
event subscription,
retrieve the Drive resource
you're interested in
and simply call add
change subscription.
But now you're
probably wondering
where these events
get delivered.
That's a good question.
To handle background
events, you need
to create a service that
extends DriveEventService
and add this class to
your apps manifest.
You'll override
the Handler method
in this class for each
event in DriveEventService
that you care about.
Let's try this out.
First, let's create
the service class
that will handle
the change events.
Create a class that
extends DriveEventService--
in this example, my
DriveEventService.
Override the onChange method in
your DriveEventService subclass
and print out the
event using Log.d.
This is where you should do any
application specific processing
that you need to do.
The last thing you need to
do is define your service
in the manifest so that
the Drive API can find it.
In AndroidManifest
and XML, create
an entry for your service.
Set the Android exported
attribute to true
and add an intent filter
for the handle event actions
so that Drive knows how
to identify your service.
Now whenever name gets updated
by another app on the device
or the Drive API download
changes from the server,
your app will receive
a change event.
Now that you've got your
DriveEventService set up,
you can easily add support for
handling completion events.
When you make a call
to the Drive API
you receive a pending
result with a status.
The pending result
status tells you
whether this action
was successfully
applied locally on the device.
But the action might not
get sent to the server
until later-- for instance,
if you're offline.
Completion events let you know
when the action has actually
made it up to the server
if it was successfully
applied on the device.
You'll only receive
the completion event
is the original call
successful, meaning the pending
result returned from that
call had a successful status.
Completion events
themselves can result
in either success,
failure, or conflict.
We'll start by looking at how
to request these notifications
and how to handle success
and failure results.
Completion events are
requested for a single action,
rather than for a single file
or folder like change events.
To request a completion event,
create an execution options
builder call set
notify on completion
and pass the new object as a
parameter in your file creation
or content update method calls.
You can also add an
optional tracking tag
to the execution options
to make it easier
to identify which action
the completion event
corresponds to.
To add a tracking tag
call set tracking tag
when you create your
execution options.
This tracking tag will
be returned to you
when the event is delivered.
To handle events
when they're fired,
use the same DriveEventService
class you created before
and override the
onCompletion method.
You can compare the
results of event.getStatus
to CompletionEvent.statuses
success
to determine whether the
action was successful.
Similarly, check for
CompletionEvent.status failure
to determine if
the action failed.
For more info on what other data
the completion event contains,
take a look at the documentation
for the completion event class.
Last, once you've processed
the completionEvent,
you need to dismiss the
event to acknowledge
that you were able to respond.
If your app can't process the
event right away-- for example,
if your app is offline and needs
to do a server query to process
it-- you can snooze the event.
The Drive API will notify you
about it again in the future.
You should dismiss or snooze
every event that you receive.
In addition to
success and failure,
actions can also
result in conflicts.
Conflicts can happen when
two apps on the same device
head at the same file
at the same time,
or when a user interacts with
your app from multiple devices.
Let's take a look at how you
can use completion events
to resolve a conflict.
Requesting a conflict
event is almost
exactly the same as requesting
a standard completion event.
The only difference is
the conflict strategy.
You set the conflict strategy
using the set conflict strategy
method when creating
your execution options.
The default strategy,
overwrite remote,
overrides any changes
on the server.
To respond to a
conflict, you need
to use the key promote strategy
to keep the remote changes.
Conflict events are a
type of completion event.
So you'll receive these events
in exactly the same way, using
the onCompletion method of your
DriveEventService subclass.
If the upload results
in a conflict,
you'll receive an event with
the status-status conflict.
Remember to dismiss
or snooze the event
when you finish processing it.
Each app will handle
conflicts differently.
You might be able to
do a three way merge
or you might want
to ask the user.
To get the server
version of the file,
open the file from the
devices you normally
would using DriveFile.open file.
As long as your online this call
will download the new version
from the server.
To get your modified
version of the file,
call
getModifiedContentsInputStream
on the completion event.
Last, to get your
original local copy
before your
modification was made,
call getBaseContentsInputStream
on the completion event.
Now compare the three
copies of the file
to create the merged
version, write this content
as you normally would
using contents.commit
and dismiss the
completion event.
See our sample
code for an example
of merging items in a task list.
You've just learned how to
use the DriveEventService
to respond to change
events, completion
events, and conflicts.
We can't wait to see what
you built with these APIs.
I'm Jen King, and
thanks for watching.